[Musique]
pour soir tous nos amis je veux voir
nicolas je peux fort propre que le
nounours est en forme ce soir
j'espère que toute notre petite famille
est sage je descends m'en rendre compte
à bientôt quatre ans dont le seul tort
d'être bouge pas tant rmi bonsoir le
petit train ils sont trop mignons
oui tant j'avais tout autour les sept
portes toto tu vas la casse et vient de
cocher bien vite au dodo d'août où l'on
a fermé la porte à clés d'autos après on
pourra plus l'ouvrir allemands ouvrent
la porte aux taux les frire petit auto
essaie de tourner la clé de tous
ton à la clé d'autant les coûts totaux
tu me du savon sur lac
[Musique]
c'est mieux
alors tourner l'aclu à présent ne fera
pas tout ça sert à rien
et là tu as tu peur de nous affolons
surtout monde mais paul le poulpe ne
nous affolons pas allant tout on enlève
la clé de la serrure la nettoie nounours
regarde par le trou au lait ou jeu du
cerveau d'en haut
j'ai une idée si on essayait une autre
clé sourit katia la queue du paka très
bien merci
ma petite pimprenelle ne t'énerve pas
d'auto attention
ja c'est beaucoup
ap leur bateau à l'eau suite et l'or
l'or cfi norauto rouste
et maintenant en dedans allez sacré
totaux allons au lit pimprenelle bonne
nuit là me
bonne nuit et me baudelot
au menu nuit non mais non jupe on ne
s'attaque pas lourd là j'étais à la
lumière tôt
[Musique]
elle
et
[Musique]
mais ben 10 amis vous avez vu ce qui est
arrivé à toto il ne pouvait plus ouvrir
la porte
il ne faut jamais s'amuser à fermer une
porte à clé c'est très dangereux au losc
moi je ne ferme jamais ne portent plus
alors faites comme nours bonne nuit les
enfants faute de preuves
[Musique]